good afternoon to everybody it is Maitre
D' in my tradition world
all around tables sharpened time
announced and thanks to the presence of
the web here so those who are late will
have opportunity to to look all the
recordings here also those colleagues in
the ivy group of universities that you
also have this opportunity to watch this
presentation well I don't know because
of the weather or something other two
colleagues there may be late but I will
start I will start with an oral honor to
present my good friends and colleagues
from the United Nations starting from
the right to the left from lady to the
to a gentleman one of the most
experienced ambassador in our community
ambassador diary of knowledge could I
[Music]
invite all the colleagues today to speak
on the global peace and security from
the prison of the original view the
regions are I invited today there they
have been in trouble like the region's
Laura is representing the Balkans
because region when the first of all
started and many other conflicts started
and so her experience and you can look
through the huge experience in the
diplomacy the top positions in the
ministry and now one of the leading
ladies ambassador to the United Nations
very active ambassador so I invite her
to speak on now mostly on Balkans but
she is not limited and - well - also -
to look at the problems globally maybe
to reflect the role of United Nations
how it works generally to settle other
problems they have view on the
developments in the region in
is everything settled in the Balkans if
no challenges this is what ambassador
will be asked for sure
after her presentation I will present a
good friend of mine ambassador of
Philippines to the reduction who I guess
very important today at a roundtable
because he is ready to bring the view on
the developments in the region of south
eastern part of the world with all these
challenges to the security coming from
the northern Korea well their relations
with such global players like China in
the region and the United States in the
region so at the experience of
ambassador is very important and not
only as a diplomat but as a politician
as a writer as a journalist and as the
parliamentarian so that's why I
represent him excited because you are
attending the school one of the best
universities in the world and I was
graduated just in a small school of
Libya and diversity but still I'm very
very honored and thank you
Yuri for inviting me what Slovenian
ambassador would speak about the
situation in Western Balkans you would
say you just got out of that mess 25 26
years ago
and now you want to speak about that it
is true Western Balkans is for Slovenian
one for Slovenia one of the highest
priority in foreign policy why because
it's our immediate
and we are interested to have stability
peace and prosperity in the region
second what is very important is that we
still believe that we have
responsibility to deliver what we
promise to and when you know the fall of
the Iron Curtain and the changes and
reforms in Europe that we are going to
make Europe whole and free again and
Western Balkans is a part of Europe and
this is why in Slovenia a strong
advocate for the integration of Western
Balkans to the European Union as well as
to the to the NATO enlargement how is
the situation today what what is 20
18 years after the the war hostilities
stop the situation is still very very
situation is still very very vulnerable
but why because of course those
countries in the in the Western Balkans
as you can see both pain hurts
we know that you are known that faced
one of the most cruel words in the world
then Serbia Montenegro Macedonia and
Kosovo are still in transition process
the transition of course requires a lot
of reforms in the area of law in the
area of human rights in the area of good
governance economy public running the
public services and so on
of course because they felt so strong
pressure during the war the those
reforms are they're very slow they put a
huge effort but also European Union and
Slovenia puts a huge effort in order to
encourage them cell phones I will speak
about those reforms a little bit later
but let me say that when you speak about
a general situation right now in those
Western Balkan countries what are the
biggest problems the biggest problem is
brain drain it started during the world
and it continues the second is last a
lack of perspective for young generation
job opportunities education also the
third I would say the need to improve
economic management and good governance
and rule of law and then of course on
top of that you have highly sensitive
political situation where you have on
one side huge sensitivities the recipes
of the war on the other side you have
increased nationalism especially in
rhetoric so this is a kind of a
combination where all the reforms are
very very difficult my country Slovenia
of course became member of the European
you
in 2004 the first country from the
package of formula was lava that became
a member intently the same year for some
a member of NATO alliance immediately
after we achieved those historic goals
that it was for Slovenia this was you
know like coming back to the West
immediately we started with very strong
advocacy in the European Union and NATO
for the enlargement process we believe
that this is the only way that we can
bring the rule of law the the open
market the human dignity respect for
human rights the plural democracy to the
Balkan countries why because European
Union works like that that we have to
agree to the common legislation that is
based on those of those rules and common
legislation represents a key community
almost 80% of all legislations in indeed
in the European Union countries so while
giving to those countries the European
perspective it means that they have to
start to prepare for membership in a way
that they have to adjust legislation
they have to accept the rules of free
economy they have to accept the rules of
it and standards of human rights of
democracy and so on so this is the best
way to make a difference in Western
balance because it is an opportunity to
join or rejoin the European Union or
join European Union which is today a
very unique entity in the world with
common foreign and security policy if
you want with the number of common
policies what what is the most important
it's an entity of countries 28 countries
where people are living in a very very
very very good condition some standards
when they enjoy all their rights when
they are protected where they can
express themselves in different
languages in different religions and so
on so we believe that this is the most
important of course there are very
concrete steps that we can we can talk
about that the European Union has a
special programs for the countries that
they're in the process of enlargement
and from of course the countries in the
region having different process of
enlargement Serbia and Montenegro are
candidates countries and we started
negotiations with them with Serbia in
2013 with Montenegro in 2012 with Serbia
we closed 14 out of 33 negotiation
chapters and went Montenegro we close
third practically we open 31 chapters
and closed three however the system of
negotiations in European Union works
like that that all chapters are open
until or are closed so it means that we
have a chapter on on I don't know on
agriculture on on Foreign Affairs on
internal affairs on trade on the
conditions for the trade of goods with
the with the certain relevance to the
health issues and so on it's very and
practically we try to regulate
everything so it is important that we
started negotiations and negotiations
are going a little bit slower than
expected but then of course we have we
have two countries in the in the tube
let say in the waiting rooms Macedonia
since 2005 and Albania since 2014 they
are waiting to open the negotiations you
would say why Macedonia 2005 I will
address this shortly later
and of course Bosnia and Herzegovina who
requests for the membership in 2016 and
they are now preparing the answers to
the questionnaire of the European Union
why the process of the European
enlargement is going so slow you would
ask it is because of several reasons
because of so-called you enlargement
fatigue that European Union was faced
with after the the large wave of
enlargement in 2004 and then a few years
after with another two countries second
we faced the economic and financial
crisis in 2007 to 2009 then we were
dealing with that which was very easy
would remember we were bailing out a
number of countries in in
in a situation the third reason is of
course that we faced another crisis
which was a migration flow migration and
refugee flow crisis in 2015 and
2000-2006 day and on top of everything
we have a brexit issue and because when
you have problems there are a lot of
problems then we have also a need in
European Union to reflect about our
constitutional constitutional
arrangement so this is the reason that
of course the enlargement process of
Western bottle is not proceeding as fast
as we would wish but there is a strong
political will European Union countries
together with Slovenia and of course
other countries in May this year on the
EU Western Balkan side summit discussed
the the strategy for the Western Balkans
and of course there was a clear message
that there is of course the window of
opportunity will be more concrete next
year in June now maybe it's very shortly
to the situation in different countries
of Western Balkans the most important
process that is ongoing right now is the
dialogue between Pristina and Belgrade
that is one of the most difficult issues
in in the Western Balkans why because of
course the is the question of the
recognition of Kosovo even in the
European Union we don't have the same
opinion for countries did not recognize
Kosovo as independent country and then
of course it's the question how they are
going to solve their
the issues especially the issue of Serbs
living in Kosovo the dialogue right now
it's going on it's very promising there
are certain novelties in that dialogue
that are really completely new like swap
of of territories however at the same
time it is one of the most demanding
processes generator European Union is
ready to facilitate and to help and of
course we are ready to support the
agreement that will reflect the decision
of two nations and two countries taking
in consideration the also the rules of a
key community rule let's say European
law the second process that is going on
that was all deadlock is the the
Macedonia issue as you are all aware
Macedonian Macedonia was blocked because
of the name issue for a number of years
in the euro-atlantic integration finally
Macedonia and Greece find a solution we
are going to have a referenda in
Macedonia on the 30th of this month and
if the referenda is going to be positive
then of course we have open-door policy
an invitation to NATO for Macedonia and
of course the continuation of
negotiations with European Union 40 for
the membership then we have this year
7th of October if I am NOT wrong the
elections in Bosnian hexaco
Bosnia and Herzegovina is still
struggling to be a functional state the
agreement the Dayton Agreement which
created a frame for the modern Bosnia
Herzegovina is challenged in many areas
but nevertheless let us hope that that
daily constitutional order will prevail
and that the elections are going to to
be a kick forward to the to the further
progress I'm taking too much time I
think thank you no thank you
Thank You indeed Larry thank you for
bringing a comprehensive view on the
region by the way you are beyond the
region not a part of the Western Balkans
well so you know it's not although you
know a lot of times the international
community even experts professors they
want to put us in the Western Balkans
however region well geographically as
well as politically politically we were
part of that region for 70 years during
the first and second it was Navi
otherwise you know we were not a part of
it yeah I am absolutely confident that
Slovenia is the best example of the
territories of the attacks against
Latvia in all the spheres of livelihood
economics and whatever so yeah good
standing with unemployment with other
standards and your example is attractive
for the rest of the of the countries in
the region what I am observing as well
all the problems and challenges they are
so similar to what we have on other
post-soviet for Soviet states with
suspicions of the former metropolis of
what we are doing how intentions to
integrate with
Europe who is with NATO so do you think
that the same you observing in the
origin so that suspicion of the NATO
membership of in Montenegro created
serious challenges to their sovereignty
there were suspicions that some of the
countries invaded the elections trying
to undermine certain if any challenges
for the for the next steps of other
countries particularly Bosnia with the
Republic ahsoka well on that way to the
European Union that I think that this is
very challenging challenging steps they
are going to to make and if any any kind
of the protection mechanism how to
bypass all these challenges
Montenegro head of course what we
observe now in Ukraine as well the
reform of capitals of the Metro polio
well so they are trying to well to
manage our sovereign rights to the what
we are going to do I speak about the
role of church
so when Ukrainian church is looking for
the the self self ruling of the Cavalia
well so I observe that the same problems
are raising in in Macedonia maybe soon
and course or maybe in other Orthodox
countries in the region that's why I
have a feeling that it is not easy for
the former employers if you want to well
to release us and to let us going the
way we want to do and am I wrong right
to bridge the similarities well
professor of course there are
similarities definitely what I would
like to say is that when it comes to the
public opinion in Western Balkan
countries about the European Union
integration it's by a large very very
strong that is that also gives us a kind
of a strength and responsibility for
slovenians you know to to support that
process for the European Union I well
you know even the Republika Srpska there
is a strong European Union let's say
vote in the Western Balkans when it
comes to military alliances it's a
little bit more complicated first of all
of course they the expression of the
state has to be very clear and when it
comes to Macedonia we have very very
explain well expression and of course
the political will the decision to join
it and hopefully the process will open
when it comes to Boston helps ago Vina
of course we are
their relations between NATO and Bosnia
and Herzegovina so Bosnia and
Herzegovina is interested to to have an
action plan of course the NATO has
certain requirements for that action
plan for Bosnia Herzegovina that they're
yet to be met so there is this is right
now the situation of course but of
course when it comes to to this kind of
if you want nation-building at one side
it's very similar like in informal
post-soviet and past Yugoslavia because
we were somehow republics we were
somehow we had certain autonomy but then
suddenly we became independent states
and we had to create our states you know
it was not an easy job I will tell you
from my experience when we started to to
sign the way we were started to lobby
for diplomatic diplomatic recognition
and then I went to some of my older
colleagues I said how are we going to
sign diplomatic relations agreements he
said I have no clue girl let's go to the
look in the books how we are going to do
that you know so that is the creating
the stage there's a very unique
historical opportunity so all those
countries - including the card is in the
post we have this unique unique
experience of building up the state and
at the same
the transition the transition the
economic reform from social resistant to
the open free-market economy from one
party system to multi-party system from
the you know limited legislation on the
area of real speech to the free of
speech and so on so that is I think the
unique historical experience that we can
share with many other nations in trouble
if you want to say yeah I thank you for
that so different experts they they have
different assessments on the perception
if we are going in that way when the
Belgrade and Pristina they are trying to
find a solution which are challenging
and I'm not asking you because all of us
we are just learning what what will be
the next but what is interesting that if
we go so succeeds with all these
negotiations will recognize that
humanitarian intervention there was
successful I would say definitely that
all interventions of international
community in western bankers helped to
bring that cruel terrible war because
the war was not happening somewhere else
it was happening you know him in our TV
rooms I call it because and it was
happening to all to the people so all
interventions European Union NATO United
Nations and all the systems that are
still in place to monitor and to help
they enormous Lee contributed to the to
the peace and security and also now
stability of well
yeah
[Music]
well thank you very much for this
question very briefly I would say that
you know luckily we have checks and
balances luckily you know in the
European Union and this is the
difference because I grew up in a in in
a system that there was lack of checks
and balances and I all the the cases
that you refer to this is a question how
European Union is going to address this
issues and and I believe that we have
they did democratic systems that
incorporated checks and balances that
eventually at the end of the day they're
going to address this issue in a right
way so I'm an optimist
Oh
[Music]
Danny to stop
well let me say that of course after the
war in western balkans
the presence of interests from different
parts of the world increased because
this was the post-war area and of course
we can notice that very strong interest
by several countries to gain their
influence in Balkans politically
economically infrastructure religious
whatever issues so we know that and this
is why we believe that you know the
whole concept of Europe whole and free
it's very important because with the
integration it means that they're going
to to come today today today to the
community of values
economically I believe that for all
countries in the process the way to
prosperity is definitely to European
Union
I don't know today do you have prime
politicians you know you don't do
something because of their ideology or
or some anymore you know you are not
kept you are not going to get elected so
this is I believe a very short answer to
the question thank you one more question
we have liver ship in several areas and
we have very positive response one of
the the initiative is a first initiative
is a political leadership where our
president
borut pahor a couple of years ago set up
the process called Bordeaux where he
invited all the presidents also Kosovo
and Serbia from that party plus Albania
and that process grew to the together
with Croatia to so-called burnt up uni
process so that is a political stream
then we have let's say leadership in at
least almost 60% of our International
Development Assistance goes to Western
Balkan countries when it comes to the
different programs implementation of the
programs of technical assistance of the
European Union Slovenia is involved in
like our implementation of for nearly 15
percent of all technical assistance
program in European
in the region so it means you know that
they they also those countries they are
asking for slovenians because of
language knowledge of the language
feeling more comfortable with the people
that you used to live in the same
country and these kind of things and
then also because we take a leadership
in some different areas like a couple of
years ago we launched in the European
Union a special project called Western
Balkan counter-terrorism initiative that
is now one of the European policies of
integrating border control management
into Western Balkans this is one of the
issues that was addressed successfully
now on the initiative of Slovenia by the
European Union it reflects excellent
cooperation between region and the Union
especially on the area of the you know
return of the foreign fighters of these
kind of issues and address the
radicalism so basically it's well
received and welcomed just to a few
words boom your important question about
it the reaction of the post you will of
countries or the European integration
and comparing who is the Central
European countries because what we have
a new creative azov ambitions to be
integrated to Europe so now I can
compare with some of the West Balkan
countries because we are we have
different starting positions in terms of
how we are going to get this opportunity
to be integrated so Central European
countries Hungary Czech Republic and
Seoul they got the membership within
European Union without in big fighting
and that's why the the God is the God
now they are understanding that they
pulled a part of their sovereignty to
Brussels
and now so they are fighting well at
least to not to bring back but at least
to control a part of the serenity
political now they are fighting not to
have the the chorus on the migration in
terms of security the same the debating
added to be in to accept the the new
initiative about the European European
security structures or whatever the the
difference in in the Western Balkans the
events will divorce and they don't think
about that a part of their serenity will
be delivered to the brussels and even
they don't think about the financial
problems italy you mentioned is facing
today who is being in the eurozone
because they pulled a part of the
financial server and to Brussels and now
Rome is demanding wealth to change some
rules either they will protest so we do
not think about that because we are
comparing the system generally
holistically with what we emerge from
and what we can be brought back so that
is why most probably all this issues
will come when there are members and
we'll see how how things will be
developed in the European Union
if European United stands well the
problems and the challenges and the
questions coming from all these new
countries so and all countries Italy
something should be done in all the
spheres and the way and the Serenity
were collected from the capitals should
be returned to them in other way of
management but at the time what I agree
with ambassador that even in Serbia
looking at the new prime minister
the president initiatives yes we can
observe they want to be out of this
visual circles which are coming from
their own past and from the from those
who were tied ideologically and who were
trying to hit to try to stop Monte
grinnell negra from the integration they
are trying to create problems for
Macedonia even bringing such as strange
issues as getting self self-governance
for their church which could be could
create a problem on their way to the
integration with that I would like to
thank ambassador she asked me as sorry
for that she asked me well to be first
we destroyed the United Nations rules
[Music]
because of gender and understanding that
you are to to host a serious event in
New York how to to be back in time and
because you spent more time coming here
because of the weather so thank you very
much and now we are moving to one
important region
[Applause]
somebody said that table is not so
around but we are trying to embrace that
it is round switch to
so now we have a short presentation yes
or whatever because the region is much
was bigger than the Western Balkans
better to the role of a seduction so
here everything about he was the big
manager it means that he knows
everything and now of course can be
attacked from other side because the
region so so dynamic so so many changes
so many reconfigure the configuration so
new new searches your leadership is
trying to to create good relations with
all neighborhood a lot of the
initiatives you are partition with Japan
well rethinking the partnership with
United States for whom with whom
Philippines has special relations be on
NATO's China's active role if not
aggressive role in the region the
challenges to the to the territorial
interests of many of the countries so
huge amount and I'm so grateful it
exactly you derive to share this nothing
Korea is a bit far from you but if you
may share on something could have a
common vision on what is going on there
I'll be helpful because well Ukraine
used to be wonderful
mr. nuclear powers at least in terms of
the quantity of the Rockets they're the
past so well it's a sprawling subject
but it will be a short presentation I'd
rather read it so that it didn't get as
clear as possible the Fox knows many
things but the Hedgehog knows one big
thing said I say a Berlin we know what
the foxy is he is the uneatable chased
by the unspeakable on horseback it must
perforce be dodgy diving into turning
any which way that presents itself a
hedgehog is a spiny creature that rolls
itself in a ball for self-protection I
thought it was a mode so I lit new one
big thing this singular focus came of
living in the dark deep in the ground
but it is not a mode it lives above
ground like the rest of Southeast Asia
in full view and easy reach of Chinese
avidity my subject is Southeast Asia
today defined as a mass tomorrow's
battle battlefield in the struggle for
mastery in Asia between China and day as
usual reluctantly reigning hegemon the
United States we weary of America's
perennial hesitation those of us who
grew up that are acclimated to the long
peace of the Cold War made possible by
the mutually assured destruction
yet punctuated by Arab displays of hot
American power Korea Indochina the near
run thing of Cuban Missile Crisis and
while still handy with victory in the
Cold War Afghanistan and Afghanistan
again then Iraq but that was power
confident unhesitating diplomats
polished and learned sporting the
indifference the personal risk in career
and their very persons characteristic of
those who have had everything from birth
it are therefore it different that a
prospect of losing it all the strong
silent type of American is gone among
the last of them James Baker and the
absolute last John McCain not always
right but when wrong
strophic Aliso but it's bold presence
was always clarifying and reassuring
they were there when they were needed
and even when not they were always there
now we get the 9 to 5s as I was told by
a retiring officer in the class dead
clandestine foreign service it has to do
with reefs in the South China Sea nobody
not even the Chinese ever thought the
name meant that China owned it
it meant the British named it because
they owned China as a Chinese civil war
won't wound down to a blue defeat by the
Reds in a spasm of hurt pride Chiang
kai-shek who bled his forces to fight
the Japanese was the Chinese were the
Chinese Communists waited it out at the
far north through a nine - line around
the belly of China extending far into
the South China Sea farther out to what
would be the surrounding coastal states
extended economic zones and continental
shelves
none of it national territory but
exclusive for their exploitation and
duty of preservation old Chinese in many
lower thought the nine - lied in school
but the few Filipinos who cared enough
thought of it as merely aspirational
metaphor from a dying regime only a
handful in high places knew its import
but they were discrete because uncertain
and so very quietly philippine president
sent armed forces quietly to occupy
islets and reefs in the South China Sea
closest to home
unfortunately closest to one's home was
also proximate if not equal to another's
the occupation spread without fanfare or
much notice it wasn't grabbing because
you were taking anything from anybody
these were rest nullius there was no one
in those places or other features as the
as the Hague Tribunal later labeled them
features yielding 12 nautical miles if
they jumped it above water at high tide
and not at all if they stayed submerged
in any case not entitled the continental
shelf or exclusive economic zone a more
technically precise explanation is in
the two volumes I'm leading
for the library later the new China we
now know took what took one of those
reefs from us and dredged and dumped
sand in it to keep it above water
habitable in a complicated and expensive
way and weaponize abode term we invented
China hopes it'll qualify as an island
generating a 200-mile exclusive economic
zone eating into ours when a continental
shelf that will include all of us
China claimed it by ancient right yeah
sure ancient like the day before
yesterday when they dredged it up
Chinese history Agra is inextricable
from wishful thinking geography shortly
before the US invasion Vietnam seized
features once taken by France and never
abandoned
maybe they're still French Vietnam did
it again after the last u.s. chopper
took off from the embassy and then they
turned around to knock out the Chinese
Army in the north
both Vietnam and the Philippines are the
most aggressive in this kept it up on a
vague notion of strategic and economic
value thus far and realized there was a
member of the board of an aggressive oil
exploration company we found nothing of
value at the stock market we were
trading in hope but they hope there
isn't anything there so we won't be
bound by honor to fight for it
the curse of oil and so it went on
Taiwan and Malaysia joined then the
bamboo curtain erected around itself by
Red China and reinforced by the US fleet
began to crumble from pressures of
enlarging economic opportunities largely
supplied say some writers by the u.s. to
counterbalance Soviet power the strong
albeit still red China in the Far East
or Far West depending on where you are
looking out from the rest you know China
overtook Japan as the second largest
economy and very soon it will overtake
the United States this still doesn't say
much in terms of military power for as
long as the projection of u.s. power
from the American mainland stays strong
China's proximate advantage of itself
being in a war theater the south in East
China Seas is also its gross
disadvantage the US can hit it from a
safe distance
across the Pacific as well as quite
close from its Asian allies if they were
allowing China will be in the thick of
the fight subject the withering fire
from its distant and moving enemy and
it's closer allies nonetheless China has
kept taking featured taking features
belonging to Vietnam and the Philippines
Indonesian power checked its advance in
that direction the tally for now China
had no presence in the Spratlys until
1988 when it clashed with Vietnam killed
84 Vietnamese civilians and then took
six more maritime features all of which
China has developed into artificial
islands China took mischief reform the
Philippines in 1995 and in 2012 poached
Scarborough one day Chinese Coast Guard
surrounded a feature belonging to the
Philippines and excluded its fishermen
Philippine Coast Guard should have
responded but our only warship was in
the area picking up part of an old North
Korean missile that had dropped there so
it went to the rescue in China called it
a belligerent app the u.s. intervened
and said both sides should back off the
Philippines did China did not without
being asked explain its uselessness the
u.s. said it is only interested in
defending freedom of navigation this
encouraged China but then Obama was
mostly Pro Chinese and like the
Republicans before him Hillary did
better asked by China with the usual
oriental indirection how the US would
respond if China sparked with the
Philippine with its Philippine ally
continued Hillary said go ask a sink
back commander who doesn't listen or
answer but simply sends out his fleet
and launches its fighters and missiles
or not China stood down but only briefly
freedom of navigation is nothing when
the u.s. exercised it by said dick part
of the u.s. 7th fleet a Chinese flotilla
welcomed it at the entrance of the South
China Sea and escorted it all the way
out its backside thereby proving two
things
it is a polite host at the South China
Sea is part of its home the swimming
pool we were outraged what was the use
of our
neutral defense treaty later Obama told
the Japanese the US would go to war with
China over the Senkaku Islands which are
uninhabited asked by the Philippine
press if he would do the same for the
Philippines he said no this was further
encouragement he gave China we were not
entirely powerless we have international
law on our side since both China and the
Philippines had signed up to own clause
we went to the Hague China refused to
participate we had verbal sea us support
which is of course worthless at least
because it was qualified the US is only
interested in freedom of navigation
which as I explained is nothing and the
US won't sign on to own clause and why
why was China so concerned and the
reason is to break out of the first
island chain of iron alliances drawn by
the United States from South Korea
through Japan Taiwan the Philippines
Vietnam Malaysia Singapore and Indonesia
which locks in China and locks out
commodities essential to China's
economic strength and military power
principally energy and then it hopes to
push the u.s. back to the second island
chain on Guam and then to Hawaii or San
Diego now there is a thriller I don't
know if any of you have read it called
tridon that envisions a scenario where
an alliance of littoral states by Japan
led by Japan interdict Chinese Commerce
in the Straits of Malacca and sink it in
the South China Sea
it ends with a nuclear demonstration
explosion by the u.s. to sober up
everybody that the economic and
political game is not really worth the
flame of a nuclear candle Kagan says
there is only the half of it the wider
gain is the Indian Ocean which Arab oil
at African rare metals must cross to
reach China after passing the Straits
the entire enchilada from source to
consumption and back again at an Indo
Pacific Theater at the Chinese control
or with significance a to the exclusion
of American presence except by leave of
the Chinese state the question for my
government the government succeeding the
one that warned the hate was whether to
keep banging our head against the Great
Wall to the applause they were useless
power and forego the benefits of Chinese
trade
credit or play along with it I myself am
still puzzled I asked a Central Asian
ambassador knowing that tans are menaced
by Russia and China he said what do you
do if a bear is running toward you do
you run it will overtake you and Molly
exasperated because you made it run do
you stand and fight it will maul you
worse for your insolence what you do is
run toward the bear and hug it tight of
course it can crush you against its
chest but not if you hug it really tight
and dance with it this much is true the
weaponize reef is the most useless
investment China ever made towards
increasing its military power and reach
because the worst thing in warfare today
is an immovable object it has caused
China the suspicion of all Southeast
Asia which is a lure which was lured by
its generous credit now they prepare for
the worst from China and there is this -
military experts say that in the first
half hour of conflict between China and
the Philippines a missile strike would
evaporate the weaponized grief the
weaponized reef indeed turned its sand
into glass yet it would not be an act of
war because the reef belongs to the
Philippines but the point would be made
out of this parochial situation as the
reason Fox and Hedgehog concerns does
the u.s. preemptively strike down
Chinese aspirations in the western
Pacific with a hedgehog focus or does it
we in and out of situations generated by
friendly and hostile relations between
China and the United States like a fox
chased by the uneatable is the u.s.
still interested in being the
indispensable power in the world or will
it be the first empire in history whose
presence is far more reassuring than
resented yet it wants to decline and
fall without a shot fired in anger or
self-respect becoming just another
continental country like Russia but with
internal freedom in the age of China
American diffidence can cite the
authority of kenan about the limits of
power but right now canon does not suit
the interests of democracy in asia and
he was even wrong that the philippine
was a foreign policy misadventure of
America without the Philippines the US
could never have contained China and of
course it could have waged the Vietnam
War which even if the u.s. lost was such
a demonstration of American firepower
communism stopped moving one other
option is to revisit us-philippine
relations and recreate some of its old
features MacArthur called Taiwan
America's unsinkable aircraft carrier
actually the Cold War Philippines was
America's unsinkable carrier group of
the coast of China just as Britain was
of the coast of Europe that can be
replicated to greater effect even
without formal US basis imagine an
entire archipelago of over 7,000 Islands
offering cover for an impossible to
track ordnance platform from any part of
which the US can strike out can strike
out and move out of range to another
part finally what is the role of the UN
I cannot imagine we cannot even raise
our issues without losing our
connections to dominant regional and
economic groupings in the u.s. in the UN
for all favor China the UN is indeed the
Parliament of man but not in a good way
at least because the u.s. keeps
threatening to pull out of it what it
won't get its way all the time
China has the means to replace the US as
the major funder of the UN and become
the major influencer in the world but
China doesn't move its contributions are
minimal maybe it doesn't think it
necessary to buy big into an institution
and an increasing American disdain when
it can set up a parallel one like the
Asian infrastructure investment bank
it's answer to the japanese-american ADB
all of America's closest Western allies
during the Chinese Bank we did not we
held back from pride and suspicion and
now we have lamely followed I hope we
get it thank
well hmm so Dora thank you unexpectedly
unexpectedly because you were so open in
in some assessments and you give now the
chance to the audience well to raise a
lot of questions because yeah and you
touch upon very comprehensive problems
in the region involving big players
global players and I open the floor for
the for your questions then I do have my
comments first I make this is my this is
my views my government now as he says
reaching out to China and at the same
time it gets mad at China whenever
lately I think Chinese fighters started
to harass Philippine planes and so the
president got angry
there is a Filipino Chinese expression
they call it soon to be our top hip
embrace hip embrace Chinese merchants
use that because well you know there are
minority and the thing the way to
survive as a minority is to well embrace
the guys who are the majority and then
hit them when they're over where they
overdo it
so me personally I just operation thing
my personal attitude that in your
comments on some big players you
performed as the as a scholar as a
lawyer as a journalist well so we we
accept it is like that so your question
[Music]
well I'm always leery of doing with the
Chinese that's just how it goes and the
thing though is that we're not getting a
help from anybody and so you have these
opportunities that are being offered
just before you ask that question I
would have wondered what to say
would it be an impossible situation if
we borrowed money from China I would
have thought so I would have thought so
particularly because China has this
thing they now in spite of having the
Asian infrastructure bank they deal
through the IMF and that's a catastrophe
the IFC the IMF the World Bank once you
deal through them we get the money of
China from them and the World Bank and
the IMF are really very good in
punishing countries that don't pay back
and now their principal founder is China
we got we were beaten up and we borrowed
money from the United States IMF World
Bank was really squeezing but it paid it
all back but we China there and that's
another thing altogether but you
remember we cannot now appeal to anyone
else because they'll say this isn't
China doing it to you this is the same
guys World Bank IMF so you went into it
you gotta pay for it fortunately then
comes
Mahavira and this is just a recent
development I think of a few months ago
and what does he do he completely
unravels a deal you say I don't want it
I like that III had dealing we had
dealings with with Mathia he's very hard
to get along with he knows everything
and he tells you that in the negotiating
table but sometimes you need a guy like
that in the table now so that's gonna be
good as you can see we don't have a
grand scheme will be playing in you know
day by day depending on the situation
now suddenly we have this wild card
which we certainly resented his
arrogance before but I think we're gonna
find him really useful in dealing with
China that's where we are now
yes sir what if I can save other
countries we have a saying in the
Philippines the way you deal with people
is soon top
Jakub so dope means hit him and then
embrace him whatever works we might have
a bit of that now with we ass here
sometimes because we have progress with
thought where it talks with China
another country will speak up against
China when there was a question of our
victory of The Hague this is very clear
but the features are ours and China said
no don't bring it up this is you know
because we're negotiating this we're
trying to come up with an amicable
settlement bilateral and so what I do is
I don't say anything but then Vietnam
says the same thing you're about to say
subject Nam says and then China says
right of reply and then I said you
exercise the right to reply and you
answer them directly I will reply yes
but we have an agreement well maybe but
I'm very forgetful
I just might answer you back so that's
it that's what it's like and in the end
like the last time Vietnam spoke upward
you know basically the Philippine
position our victory of The Hague and
they they said right of reply and I said
well
if you really trench on that subject
there's no holds barred and then so he
decides to read a tank poem so I tore up
my answer that I bowed to him and he
bout to be any walked out so I think
that sort of thing will work for a while
but not I don't know for how long
meanwhile do you know what's a good part
of it they haven't found oil and that
really is a curse
who doesn't want oil I don't I never did
even before once that things there
that's the end of your country no it's
not very clear because the United States
is also not very clear at this point but
that's fine because it happens you're
not changing administrations wherever
other hopeful with with President Trump
he's they can get aggressive but right
now it's not sure where we stand so we
just stand on our our victory at The
Hague which clearly said these features
belong to us we have the 200-mile
economic zone
these are reefs they only generate at
best if they're permanently above the
surface 12 nautical miles what the
Chinese did was they they poured sand it
took a Filipino businessman to supply
the sand and and cover the reef then
created an entire weaponized island it
can land bombers if US missiles
it was radar he does everything Jesus
but but that's they said it's an island
but it's very clear that if it wasn't an
island before it's not an island now so
I was well when I was with with the sink
back it's pretty clear that having those
weaponized reefs now close to the
Philippines as a projection of Chinese
power from the coast from the coastline
it's not all that great to deal one is
it cannot move so in the event I think
the I won't ascribe it to anyone but a
commander said
within the first 30 minutes of a
conflict between the United States and
China that weaponize reef will be turned
to glass because a thermal bomb will
simply turn the sand into glass and
that's all it takes 30 minutes they're
helpless why did China get it there are
two there are two reasons once one is
that you need to lay a submarine cable
which from China to the reef which
identifies gives out the profile of a
submarine or a battleship or whatever it
is that moves I saw this myself over at
the CIA but 30 years ago you know I
think it even comes out in a movie the
profile of a battleship caps out the
minute a battleships engine starts
anywhere in the world well who cares
about that now this what somebody said
you know you just irritated a possible
ally in the Philippines to lay this
cable that will draw a profile of
whatever's crossing but that's what
they've done as I said it's completely
vulnerable whereas 7,200 islands of the
Philippines with the what the United
States Navy thinks was a bad deal they
bought small ships fast-moving ships
that can fire two or three missiles only
the very vulnerable there you can if you
fire a gun at them I think a bullet will
go through but it doesn't matter because
there's so many of them and they can
hide among all our islands 7,200 islands
fire from any of them you'll never know
what hits you so the the reef they
weaponized is worthless and on top of
which if the US were to respond and hit
those reefs say the moment of anger it's
not an act of war against China we said
it's ours so they just blew up a real
that's fine so that's a situation where
inbound
well their allies are doing exactly the
same via Thomas actually lost more and
more they call them features because
they disappear at high tide has lost
more of those and China has reclaimed
them into what they call islands but
remember that's not recognized in
international law either God made them
Islands or they never are gonna be
Islands so
Vietnam has its own thing it
occasionally gives war rhetoric on one
side sometimes we did in the past and
then the next country will do it we just
pass it around meanwhile we deal with
China we're but were however more
careful in the Philippines because
there's something about the Philippines
we went into a debt crisis in 1983 but
unlike other countries in Asia we only
get burned once so it was a huge debt
mostly to the New York banks and we had
a President Aquino who was my my boss
where she's a lady so the landlord and
she says you always keep your word you
borrow money you paid back so we did we
paid it back since then we have been
very careful about credit so we're very
leery of taking Chinese loans so that's
the one way where they can get us but as
you can see Malaysia can simply turn its
back on Chinese financing so apparently
this can be done question is how long
our only concern is that Chinese power
will drive the United States beyond the
first island chain that will increase
the I guess you call it the travel time
of a missile strike if it goes to Guam
the worst if it goes to Hawaii or San
Diego that makes it a bit harder for us
so our demo the whole thing really turns
on it happens in the Uniting American
history it's not really an imperial
power so we call it an empire of Liberty
it's there and then suddenly doesn't
feel this sense of possession
doesn't serve a good purpose that pull
back this is what were worried about
that they pull back so and so far it's
where they were waiting for another
perhaps this administration will
eventually decide that America wants to
come back in full force into Asia
the indo-pacific economic view the
you're saying is this is there such a
move for America to extend its to re
extend its in first cuz the Indian Ocean
was an American Lake as was the Pacific
in the South China Sea it still they are
still I think although I can only use
anecdotal evidence I have been to to
Pearl Harbor and those ships not exactly
look brand new so but who am I to say
I'm not a naval architect the Chinese
have their own two carriers now but two
carriers don't make a naval power so
right now there is some hesitation the
part of the United States and I can
understand that I've heard Americans say
we get a fix put our house in order or
economic house in order before we start
going out there again and I think I
myself think there's time before China
can move with any with any sustaining
force into the areas vacated by American
power
but though what do I feel about American
power
it is the indispensable power we will
not always say it and maybe that's
really unfair to the United States but
it is
I also feel that we should carry our
share of the middle of the burden of
maintaining that security for for
democracy's innovation well you pull
back I cannot imagine what kind of a
world that would be
but it'll be a world that is what I
guess from facilities strong will do
what they like a weak will suffer as
they must whatever else has been wrong
with the history of the United States at
the end of the road it's come out better
than it would have if America was not
there it's just the way it is it's
something to that so student raised a
question about the new initiative of
United States in the region the name is
in the Pacific economically
IPE V so Saturday from Paris edited in
Singapore mmm you know that the United
States frozen its interest in the
transatlantic Pacific free-trade zone or
the Obama and then the new
administration suggested that it would
be better not to be in multilateral
agreements with everybody but to be in
bilateral agreements and the
multilateral umbrella so this exactly
what is going on in after NAFTA is being
frozen and United States is rebuilding
NAFTA on the principles of bilateral
agreements now it happened with Mexico
and Canada being invited the same for
into a specific economic view so United
States is proposing new approach as I
understand it well to have bilateral
agreements with the countries in the
region but an umbrella of this
initiative it doesn't mean that they
will be by a bomb body by the
multilateral
[Music]
obligations well to create a free trade
zone in the region but to have free
trade zones or liberate the the trade
within the within the bilateral treaties
and agreements this is a bit different
approach to the maybe it's in new
economic order which is being drafted
now but it is this is the proposal which
well now is a debating in the in the
region to explain some of us might see
that as a dangerous development we take
refuge in multilateralism that's
something I'm particularly crazy about
but right now the Chinese are saying no
this thing should always be bilateral do
you deal with us on the reefs that they
stole from you basically don't bring in
outside parties like the international
ICJ Court of Justice we'll just do it
ourselves problem with that is you're
dealing with an elephant in well
actually elephant with peace in the room
and you're a pygmy so we'd rather keep
it multilateral yeah thank you have if
the u.s. comes up in this initiatives of
regional arrangements to the detriment
of multilateralism and the problem with
that is what to stop the Chinese to say
how about us by the way we're much
nearer you than they are and our fleet
is just there at the harbour the big
guys they are playing the role they want
to play so and for for China if it is
well good for them to be in a
multilateral so they are moving to the
central in Eastern Europe and joining
so-called
sixteen plus one initiative when they
are investing in the central in Eastern
Europe well very easily not bilaterally
but multilateral there when it comes to
the bilateral interest so they are doing
that so and to contribute to your
presentation when
how again I found a lot of the
similarities between what the big were
different bird is doing in the region
and what another Big Bird is doing in
average so there is no exact remedy only
the natural observation that for seven
month in the year during the winter
period the bird is sleeping and it's
most probably good time for us to escape
looking at the reefs it's good well to
demonstrate something to you because
it's very similar when you said about
the sands what why China needs these
sweeps we know the Chinese a big country
or a small territory they need more
space for enlarging population so this
is probably this risk for that purpose
they're bringing sense for that how many
they can bring their actually very few
absolutely doesn't have its old what
Russians started to do the same in in
the Kerch Strait in Ukraine bringing
sand and to enlarge this space there
well to enlarge the they the next are
the Crimea not because they need more
territories they have a lot of their own
but they needed it for the purpose you
mentioned military militarization and
expand to expand the military presence
and look what they are doing in Azov sea
today so they are trying to control all
the all the zone by military means well
what they are doing in the look in the
in the Crimea so they are changing the
balance of the strategic balance in the
region which most probably China is
planning to do the same because from
from here look
they are bringing more and more attack
missile systems not defense
Tech sitting there covering the whole
region and what is more dangerous you
create demilitarized ourselves at the
beginning of knidos well and I find a
lot of the similarities and because
there their interest is just explained
by the leadership that poor absorb so
this is so but this is another story to
bring here but so it taxes me that
because of the problem of traffic's he's
not here but my my observation is that
we have two guys big guys on the
permanent seats who are behaving in a
very strange manner this similar manner
very aggressive manner well and trying
to expand their zones of interests even
these alts never been in the historic
frames so and but the thing is the
Philippines has always been sympathetic
to Red China I was the one of the first
journalists to enter Red China and
report no matter if they were able to
achieve as opposed to the chaos of their
civil war we had a dictator by then but
never mind he was still our president
and he recognized China and extended
every courtesy to China and what do we
get out of it so they take the reefs
it's a slap in the face
was that necessary it's a little Gary of
course all of this has been happening in
a worse scale to Vietnam but then
Vietnam I guess the the West as a people
attitude towards it it is communist you
know I've had that history but we're a
little luckier because we don't have
common borders there's nothing like the
stopping power of water to slow down
aggression so far yeah after the quiz
you don't you're right there
well through so but after the collapse
of the Soviet Union and the whole system
the West the liberal democracies they
recounted that with this collapse so the
the countries of the post Soviet Union
in China would proceed and enjoy the
liberal way of living and so on and
invested in that liberal way but it was
a mistake it was a mistake because now
everybody understands that no liberal
Russia was possible from the very
beginning because Oh Sergei Kharitonov
is the chief global adviser to Putin and
his recent statement was that on the top
Russia deliberately resisted the liberal
world order from the very beginning
read this statement of Minister Kosovo
on December 1992 in his Stockholm
well from from there it was so obvious
that this state would never never move
through the liberal way of burning its
statehood and so and now we have totally
illiberal electoral democracy but not
something which were supposed to be in
Alan itis as well Regina
so everybody suppose the China through
the open market could turn to the
liberal way of development
actually China could actually continue
this way but why they would do
provocative things like cease Arif it's
a potential partner of the Philippines
you still have to cross the South China
Sea to get to us
and the 7th fleet is still there but why
do would they do that
what excuses Chinese will say well you
know things are not always nice at home
we have our military faction how do we
know they're telling the truth how do we
know they're not all in one room say
today you played the back a bad guy and
they were the good guys it's really
strange for all of us at all because
China succeeded by introducing soft
power that's right
soft expansion through the trade
investment in Seoul and I think it's
premature to their Navy is a far cry
from the evidence for the military
purpose just to supervise these day
passes in zone to control there was a
time when I had to work like that they
had to work with the Pentagon you know
they would say you need a you need a
wire from one end of the South China Sea
to the other across so that when it
comes every time a ship crosses the
profile actually comes out in a computer
street I mean that was really exciting
30 years ago to see something like Star
Wars it's a joke now I think now you can
actually see the thing from the sky so I
don't know why China had to do that
there's the only explanation for the for
the taking of the reef to lay a cable to
identify the ships apparently
thank you bye sir thank you so much
thank you to be with those who are
watching on the web in many universities
so thank you for your openness openness
so we will continue I invite everybody
for to the reception which is served
only on the second floor on the second
floor and we continue informal
discussion
this is the the Philippines I filed the
claim of the hague there certain
features and we want we want actually as
lawyers will tell you because we really
narrowed it down and said what are these
features instead of saying it's ours are
they entitled to anything any any
nautical you know distance for
territorial claim I mean we got nothing
which is perfect since we got nothing
why would you want it because one thing
that sure is we have a 200-mile economic
zone where all these features they're
basically the decision says nothing so
we just start tryna you get you to you
took one you're welcome to it but it
doesn't generate anything does the
decision is not so your because it give
us right so thank you why do you go to
the big library and another will be in
the library of the Macmillan Center
thank you very much for you
[Applause]
[Music]
you